vamos con nuestro invitado del día la
guerra en Etiopía pudo haber sido la más
mortífera del mundo en lo que va del
Siglo 21 aunque solamente ha durado dos
años algunas estimaciones apuntan a que
más de 600.000 personas fueron
asesinadas esto significaría un promedio
de más de 820 asesinatos Al Día si bien
en noviembre del 2022 se firmó un
acuerdo de paz la gran pregunta que nos
queda es que está ocurriendo en el
terreno esto lo analizamos con nuestro
primer invitado y conectamos por ello
con David Soler él es analista
internacional de asuntos africanos y
también fundador del medio digital
África mundi Muchísimas gracias a usted
por estar con nosotros
Muchas gracias Ángela sintilaciones
comenzamos académicos europeos la Unión
Europea Estados Unidos y hasta el
enviado de la unión africana para el
cuerno de África dicen que los muertos
en este conflicto en dos años fueron
unos 600.000 pero algunos estamentos del
gobierno etiope hablan de entre 80.000 Y
100.000 a qué se debe la dificultad para
entender con precisión cuántos
fallecidos nos ha dejado este conflicto
bueno es que ha sido un conflicto de dos
años en los que ha habido un bloqueo
absoluto a los periodistas por lo tanto
no sabemos ni se puede saber ya no solo
periodistas agentes humanitarios
verificadores de la ONU nadie ha podido
entrar Entonces si tú no entras en un
país No sabes lo que ocurre no Al final
el Gobierno Federal del liderado por el
Primer Ministro habíasmed también le
interesa no poner un poco menos esa
cifra Entonces es normal que varíe tanto
es como cuando hay una gran
manifestación y una parte dice una cosa
y la otra parte dice otra esa es el
principal motivo no el Gobierno Federal
ahora quiera hacer
un punto y final y cuenta nueva no Por
decirlo así para intentar unificar otra
vez Etiopía y dar esa imagen no de país
estable y no quieren que se investiguen
potenciales crímenes contra la humanidad
que han ocurrido por ambas partes por la
parte de los y por la parte del gobierno
etíope entonces de ahí la divergencia
pero me creería más ese número grande de
600.000 incluso Estados Unidos dijo en
torno a medio millón 500.000 nunca se va
a saber el número exacto y esa es la
pena y además aquí cabe preguntarse si
esto incluye a las personas que
fallecieron por la crisis de alimentos
que empeoró con la guerra
Sí sí por supuesto Claro en esos 600.000
o 500.000 ya digo un número que jamás
sabremos a ciencia exacta Cuál es se
incluyen muertos de hambre o sea el tres
de cada cuatro personas en tigray
durante estos dos años necesitaba comida
para vivir creo que los números eran en
torno a 5 millones esas tres de cuatro a
cuatro personas esto significa
básicamente que ya no es una persona
muerta por un embarazo no por un disparo
o activamente participando en la guerra
estamos hablando de niños muertos por
inanición estamos hablando de mujeres
estamos hablando de ancianos también
también animales no que al final si no
entraba comida
al terreno Pues bueno sin fallece tu
ganado luego no tienes de Qué comer no
es una región muy agrícola y al final la
gente dependía de lo que cultivaba y del
ganado y las reses que tenían entonces
obviamente ese número tan grande que no
entienda la gente no que es directamente
por disparos sino por las consecuencias
de una guerra y un bloque humanitario
que que forman parte no de todo lo que
es el conflicto Pues como siempre pasan
los conflictos Rosa los ridículo y Rosa
la indignación más allá de este número
exacto de muertos que finalmente es una
cifra sin duda podríamos decir que esta
ha sido una de Las Guerras más duras de
las últimas décadas
cómo explicar lo que ha sucedido allí en
comparación con otros conflictos de la
envergadura por ejemplo de Siria de
yemen incluso de Ucrania
bueno es una guerra que no empieza ahora
no Etiopía es un país que se considera
ese mismo Federal pero más concretamente
en no Federal Qué quiere decir esto que
cada estado regional lo domina una etnia
Entonces los tigray que es donde ha
ocurrido esta guerra ahora han tenido
siempre El poder del partido político eh
que gobernaba el país hasta que llegó el
Primer Ministro amen en 2018 Los tigres
se llevan muy mal poner eritrea que es
un país que a su vez se independizó de
Etiopía en 1991 después de la época
comunista y desde entonces habían
mandado ellos no los tiran Vale ahora
desde que llega el viaje dice No mira no
vamos a dar ese poder a los tigres sino
que cada uno tiene que tener un poder Y
de alguna manera intentar unificar y
pasar no de la tribalización a una
unidad nacional no es fácil decirlo los
tigray todo empezó la llama no de alguna
manera porque celebraron elecciones en
una época en el que el gobierno no lo
permitía por tema de covid Y a partir de
ahí el gobierno tuvo ya la excusa para
decir que estaban haciendo desobediencia
civil invadir la región e intentar
quitar esa cúpula fuerte que había
mandado antes que él ahí es un poco por
decirlo así resumido no el el la chicha
del conflicto de cómo nace ese conflicto
de ahí a que haya sido tan brutal
bueno es una situación un país que ha
tenido muchísimos conflictos no lo tiene
solo un tigre y ahora mismo noromia que
es la propia etnia del Primer Ministro
también se levanta contra él porque se
creían que iban a ser beneficiados y no
lo son tanto
y luego el bloqueo humanitario ha sido
muy difícil estar en una zona que está
en el noreste de Etiopía justo frontera
con eritrea eritrea que antes podíaba
Etiopía porque mandaban los tigray ahora
apoyaba a Etiopía contra los trigal y
tenía fuerzas allí entonces era muy
difícil entrar tenían los bloqueos es
una zona de difícil acceso también muy
agrícola las carreteras no están muy
desarrolladas tampoco hay muchas
imágenes satelitales lo poco que hemos
podido saber de presencia de tropas y de
muertes ha sido gracias a imágenes
satelitales Pero son muy escasas
Entonces eso lleva un poco también a la
brutalidad no de todo lo que pueda
ocurrir allí y
atenciones que vienen de antes pero que
ahora han explotado también si me
permite hacer un inciso hay que tener en
cuenta que me lo dieron el Nobel de la
paz en 2019 por precisamente
reconciliarse con eritrea y permitir que
volvieran presos políticos de Canadá y
Estados Unidos eso también envalentonado
al Primer Ministro a poder hacer esto a
yo tengo la potestad para hacer lo que
quiera muy rápidamente porque ya nos
quedamos sin tiempo que ha pasado
después del acuerdo de paz que se firmó
en noviembre del 2022
Bueno yo soy cauto pero optimista de
momento se está desmovilizando las
fuerzas estaba ganando no el Gobierno
Federal de Etiopía después de un último
empuje entonces han llegado a un acuerdo
que es más favorable al gobierno
nacional Federal se está desmovilizando
las milicias regionales de tigray y
ahora a salir las fuerzas eritreas y las
amaras que son de otra etnia de Etiopía
que combatían junto con el Primer
Ministro Entonces poco a poco vemos como
que se van viendo las armas empieza a
entrar la ayuda humanitaria pero aún así
dicen las asociaciones y ongs que las
situaciones muy incómoda que la paz es
muy frágil y hay que tener cuidado a ver
qué ocurre este año para que no vuelvan
las hambruna y todas las demás crisis
humanitarias que se derivaron de este
conflicto además queda eritrea que
aunque respaldó al Gobierno Federal le
de etiopiano hizo parte de las
negociaciones y tigre y sigue
denunciando que siguen matando civiles
incluso después de la firma no así que
bueno son preguntas que nos quedan
gracias a usted de David Soler analista
internacional para los asuntos africanos
Muchas gracias